RICK SMOLAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: All
right, welcome.
So to start, I think
I speak for myself
and many people in
the audience when
I say being a professional
photographer is very cool.
And I've definitely thought
that being a National Geographic
photographer and going
and chasing adventure
and action is just
something so unbelievable.
So how did you first become
interested in photography,
and how did you later decide
to turn it into a career?
RICK SMOLAN: I think that
probably my answer is probably
very similar to almost
any other, at least
male, photographer
you ask, which
is I was painfully
shy when I was a kid.
And my dad gave me a
camera when I was 14.
It was the first time I could
go over and talk to girls.
Seriously.
I mean, every
photographer I know,
even the ones that
are the most outgoing,
are kind of shy underneath.
And it was just a great excuse.
It also allowed me to
transition from group to group.
Well, when I was
growing up, I always
thought that most people
had a gene that taught you
how to talk to strangers and
it was left out of my kit
when I was born.
And I thought if I watched
other people enough,
I could learn how to do it.
So being a photographer,
it's sort of be-there,
but-not-be-there.
So I can hang out with the jocks
or the nerds or the freaks.
Or I could move in and
out of different groups,
and everybody
accepted me because I
tended to make them look good.
And I never studied photography.
It was my hobby.
My dad was adamant about me
not being a photographer when
I told him I wanted
to be a photographer.
When I grew up, I didn't
know what that meant,
but he wouldn't let
me go to a college
where they had a
photography program.
He said, I'm not going to
pay for you go to school
and end up doing wedding
pictures and baby portraits.
I want you to be a doctor or
a lawyer or some serious job.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Don't
listen to your parents.
See how wrong they were?
RICK SMOLAN: So I did the
yearbook in high school
and in the newspaper, and
I just loved photography.
It was just fun.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: That's fantastic.
So do you remember what was
your first major assignment when
you were like, oh man,
this could actually
be something I want
to do with my life?
RICK SMOLAN: A
friend of mine-- I
used to read "Popular
Photography."
Back then, it was really
the equivalent to the blogs.
And a friend of mine
in college one day
read that "Life"
magazine was doing
"One Day in the
Life of America."
And he bet me $25.
He thought I was a much better
photographer than I did.
I was always very insecure.
I still am.
And he bet me that I could
get hired by Life magazine.
So I took a train
to New York City.
I was in Pennsylvania.
And I had my yearbook
and a box of pictures.
I had no appointment.
I just show up at the
Time Life building,
and I'm dressed in jeans
and sneakers and a t-shirt.
And I go to the reception
desk, and the woman says, yes,
can I help you?
And I said, I'm here to see
the editor of "Life" magazine.
And she goes, do you
have appointment?
I said, no.
I read about this issue
that you guys are doing.
And she said, well,
you can't just
show up here without
an appointment.
I'm sorry.
And she waves me
out of the building.
And I'm walking out
of the building,
and there's all these guys
walking in jeans and t-shirts
bringing packages wrapped up
in brown paper with string.
So I had this sort
of crazy idea.
So I went around to Sam
Flax, wrapped up my yearbook
in paper and string, and
then followed these guys
into the freight elevator
and got up to the floor.
And, of course, when I got out
and then went to the reception
desk, the woman there said,
well, who's the package for?
I said, well, no, actually, I'm
here to see the photo editor.
As she said--
MEI-MEI ZHAO: It
might be illegal,
but at least it
got you in there.
RICK SMOLAN: So she got
really angry and she said,
you have to get out of here.
So I go back to the elevator.
I remember I push
the Down button.
I was standing there.
I was thinking,
what would the hero
do in a movie at
this moment, like
if you're writing
this as a movie?
And I thought, this woman
works for "Life" magazine,
and she probably never
gets to see the pictures
until they come out.
I had this thing
about "Life" magazine.
If you were the secretary,
all your friends
would say it's so cool
to work at "Life,"
but she probably
doesn't see anything.
So I thought, I'll go back.
I'll just show her two
of my favorite pictures.
She'll kick me out, but at
least I'll feel like I tried.
So I went back to her desk.
She's on the phone.
And I get that look like,
what the hell are you
doing back here?
But she's talking to somebody.
And I'm standing
there trying not
to make eye contact, because
I know if I look at her,
she's going to go,
get out of here.
And some guy walks out
of one of the offices,
and I'm looking down trying not
to make eye contact with her.
And this guy walks out.
I remember looking down, and
he had jeans and sneakers
on like me.
So I figured he was
also not important.
And he said, hey
kid, what are those?
And I had these pictures,
and I was shaking.
I was so nervous, because
the more this went on,
the more I'm just
feeling terrible.
And I said, oh, just
some of my pictures.
He goes, can I see the?
And I said, yeah, sure.
And he looked through then and
he said, these are really good.
He said, what are
you doing here?
And I just sort of lost it.
I said, I came all the way
from my college and nobody
will talk to me and
all I want to do
is just show my
pictures to the editor.
He said, OK, calm down.
Calm down.
He said, I'm Grey Villet.
I'm the senior photographer
here at "Life,"
and I really like your pictures.
And if you wait a minute,
I'll go back and talk
to John Loengard, the
director of photography,
and I'll see if he can see you.
This woman gets off the
phone, and I've just
done what she's paid not
to allow ever to happen.
And so he comes back
out, and he said, John.
I thought he was going
to say, he can't see you,
but thank you.
And he said, John's really busy.
And he said, if you
don't mind waiting,
it might be an hour or two.
It's like, I'll
sleep on the couch.
I'll wait all day.
It was not inconvenient.
So about an hour
later, he comes out.
And this guy comes out and
say, hi, I'm John Loengard.
Come back in my office.
And he said, what do you got?
So I showed him my yearbook,
and I had some prints.
I'm thinking, really?
I mean, I brought my yearbook?
I couldn't have even
done a portfolio?
And he goes through and he
says, these are pretty good.
He said, so what
can I do for you?
And I said, well,
I saw that you're
going to do this "One Day
in the Life of America."
And I said, I was hoping maybe
you'd might like to hire me?
And he said, well, you
know, we've already
hired 99 photographers,
and the whole concept
is 99 photographers one day.
He said, why don't you take
some pictures and send them in?
And I remember taking
this deep breath
and I said, Mr. Loengard, my
whole life growing up I've
been reading "Life" magazine,
and I would just do anything
if I could really be part of
the team, like, to be official.
And I thought I'd
blown it, because he
had no expression
on his face at all.
And he just sat there
and he just stared at me.
And I remember I was
dripping with sweat,
and he's just staring at me.
Then I see a little smile
in the corner of his mouth.
He goes, well, I guess
it wouldn't financially
bankrupt Time Life if we
made it 100 instead of 99.
He said, OK, you're hired.
So that was my first job.
And I photographed two
of my friends taking
a shower together at college.
And her father turned out
to be a Baptist minister.
And this was the
picture everyone
talked about, because kids naked
in college-- what a concept,
right?
But it was the one
picture everybody
talked about when
the issue came out.
So then I met the
people at "Time,"
and suddenly I had a job.
And I'd never
studied photography,
so I'm glad my friend
bet me the $25.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: That's incredible.
So I think a lot of
us here can relate,
because the Google job
interview process is--
RICK SMOLAN: I've heard.
It's the gauntlet.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: But it
seems like you also
went through quite
the interview,
but we're really
glad you got the job.
So I watched your TED Talk.
And so one of the projects
that you chose to pursue
is documenting
Amerasian children.
RICK SMOLAN: For those
of you who don't know,
Amerasian children are American
fathers and Asian mothers,
which happens wherever we
have troops in the world.
Nothing to do with being at
war, but wherever we have bases,
there are children being born
as a result of these bases.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, so
if you guys have time,
if you have or
haven't watched, it's
a really incredible TED Talk.
Do you mind giving us a
little bit more details
about that project
in particular?
RICK SMOLAN: I'll
try to do it quickly,
because as a photographer,
I had trouble staying
outside of the things
I'm photographing.
I tend to get very
emotionally involved
in the stories I shoot.
And I think all of
us, as photographers,
hope that we're not
just documenting things,
but maybe our pictures
could actually
have an effect on
people's lives.
I mean, I think that's the
dream of every photojournalist.
I also want to say that
there's a real difference
between paparazzi,
fashion photographers, war
photographers, photojournalists.
Because they have a
camera around their neck
doesn't mean they're
all interchangeable.
And there's certain
code of ethics
and certain
emotional things that
go along with different
kinds of photography.
And I love being
a photojournalist,
because I think journalist is
the part of it is you're not
just taking pictures,
but you're trying
to shine a light on
something and some injustice.
You hope that your pictures may
actually touch somebody's life
or change them.
So I found out that there
were 40,000 children who
have fathered by GIs
all over Southeast Asia.
And in many of these
countries, the children,
by the local governments,
are considered
to be children of Americans.
And the American
government considers
these to be the children
of prostitutes or whatever.
These kids are stuck in this
horrible diplomatic limbo,
and through no fault of
their own, obviously.
But they're prejudiced against.
They're beaten up.
They're made fun of.
All of us growing up,
somebody would make fun of us
because we had a big
nose or big ears.
You would imagine, from
your earliest memories,
people ridiculing you simply
because of the reason that you
came to be.
So I thought, at
the beginning, this
was the bad GIs getting
the poor girls pregnant
and leaving them.
But when I actually when out
and started spending time,
I found that everybody
was using everybody.
The GIs wanted to
get laid, right?
And the girls, in
some cases, wanted
to get pregnant, because
their families had said,
if the guy marries you
and takes you to American,
then we can all come.
And so all I cared about were
these poor kids, because I just
thought, as a kid that was
really shy and made fun of,
I could really identify with
a lot of these children.
It was a three-day
story for Time Magazine,
but I got so
disturbed by it that I
decided I would take
six months off and find
six kids in different
countries and go
back and forth amongst the kids.
And my fantasy was that the
story would get published,
and I would send a copy of it to
every congressman and senator,
and people would do so outraged
that something would happen.
I couldn't find a
single American magazine
that would tell the story.
What?
Illegitimate children
of American GIs?
Forget it.
We're not going there.
I mean, nobody would publish it.
I finally found a
German magazine.
And at the last
minute, they ended up
pulling all the strongest
pictures, because they
were worried it was going
to offend their advertisers.
So in the middle of
doing this story,
I met this one
little girl who was
unlike all the other children.
She was not cowed by this.
She didn't seem to be haunted.
In fact, she was popular.
She was the most American of
any kids that I photographed.
And long story short, in the
course of photographing her,
her grandmother,
who had raised her
and had done a wonderful
job of raising her
in this little village up
along the DMZ in South Korea
but near North Korea--
the grandmother
died and left her
to me in a will.
I was 28 years
old, and suddenly I
had this 11-year-old that
looked American, didn't
speak a word of English.
And I won't tell you the whole
story, but it's on ted.com.
And it's exciting to
think that a million
people have watched it.
And she's sort of like
my kid sister now.
And our children-- the strangest
part is my kids are 12 and 14,
and her kids are seven and nine.
So our children have
sleepovers together now.
And part of my brain still
can't quite get around that.
I still think of her as
this 11-year-old girl.
And she is more mature and
smarter and wiser than me,
and she has been since
the day I met her.
And I've given you the
CliffsNotes version
of the story, but when you
see the pictures of this girl
and you see her
story and how she's
touched other people's lives.
And I've never
published the story.
I just decided the
best gift I could
give her is to put
the pictures in a box
and put them in the closet.
And now that her
daughter's almost 11,
which is the age that I met
her at, she's been saying,
why don't we do a book?
It would be fun
to do a book now,
because it's sort
of like full circle.
So I think Natasha's story and
now this new movie, "Tracks"--
both are labors of love for me.
They're both things that I got
very emotionally involved in.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, it
would be great to have
Natasha come in a TED Talk.
She seems to be
quite the young lady.
It'll be--
RICK SMOLAN: She's
so poised and funny.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: She
is, and it's amazing
how you're able
to capture so much
of her character in your photos.
And it would be
great to follow up
with her to see what
she's up to these days.
RICK SMOLAN: You know what
I thought would be fun?
I realize that we
have very little time,
and thank you all
so much for coming.
I was wondering if we jumped
to the trailer for "Tracks"?
It's a two-minute trailer.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, of course.
RICK SMOLAN: Mei-Mei, can I
set it up just one second?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah.
So yeah.
So Rick has also been working on
a book for the movie "Tracks."
So "Tracks" is a movie
that-- you know what?
I'm just going to
let Rick tell you.
But it's about Rick's
journey through Australia.
And it originally was a
book made into a movie.
And now Rick is writing
a book about the movie.
RICK SMOLAN: And about
the original trip.
It's sort of one of those--
what is it?-- the Russian dolls.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: [INAUDIBLE],
but it was quite interesting.
So yeah.
So please give us a little
description about the project.
RICK SMOLAN: So I'll set
it up really quickly, which
is before the Natasha story,
before the Amerasian story,
"Time Magazine" sent me to
the Outback of Australia
to do a cover story
on Aborigines.
And there was a
woman I've been told
to contact who was
a social worker that
worked with Aborigines to
take me into the campus
to get permission.
And so I checked into
my hotel, and the woman
who I had hired-- I
hadn't met her yet,
but she lived down the street.
I meet her down the street.
I walked into my
hotel, and I looked up,
and the most beautiful woman
I'd ever seen in my life
is washing the
windows of my hotel.
And I was 20 years old.
I had three cameras
around my neck.
And I took some pictures of
her, and she got really angry
and started yelling at me
to put my damn cameras down,
and who the hell are you?
And so I walked
over and apologized,
but I couldn't really
calm her down, so I left.
And I shot pictures
of Aborigines all day
with this woman who
took me to the camps.
And the woman working
for me said, what are you
doing for dinner tonight?
I said, I'm going to go
back and work on captions.
And she said, well, a group of
us that work with Aborigines
are having dinner
at a friend's house.
Would you like to come and
meet some other people involved
in the aboriginal
community and movement?
So I went to this house
on the outside of town,
and it was falling down and
the walls were crumbling.
There was no roof,
and I thought,
this can't be the right address.
And I knocked on the
door, and of course
who opens the door
but the woman who'd
been watching the
windows of my hotel
who was not happy to see me and
told me to put my cameras down.
I couldn't photograph
her friends.
It's like, OK.
So I walk in and she's got
camels tied up in the backyard.
And I said, why do
you have camels?
And she wouldn't tell me.
So I went to the
woman working for me
and said, why does
your friend have camels
and why is she so mean?
Sorry I took a picture of
her, but I didn't actually
kill anybody or anything.
And she said, oh,
Robyn's going to walk
2,000 miles across the
Outback of Australia
from here through the desert
out to the Indian Ocean.
And said, why?
And she said, we
don't know, and we
want to go because we're afraid
she's going to die out there.
She won't let any of
us come, and we're just
terrified that she's
going to disappear.
So anyway, during the week,
I kept meeting these people.
At the end of the week,
the woman working for me--
it was my last day there.
And she said, Robin
wants to ask you a favor,
but she's been kind of mean to
you and now she's embarrassed.
And I said, what's the favor?
I thought maybe she wants copies
of my pictures or something.
And she said, well, she wrote to
National Geographic a year ago
and asked if they would
give her money so she could
buy the saddles and
the special equipment
that she needs to
survive out there,
and they never even answered.
And she thought maybe
you might know somebody,
if she could use your
name, because she doesn't
want to spend another year
washing windows and waiting
on idiots in pubs.
And I said, well, I've met some
of the editors at workshops.
I mean, working for National
Geographic was something when
I'm 90 years old,
if you're lucky.
So I said sure, thinking
that would be the end of it.
I went back to New
York and I got a call
a week later from the editor
of National Geographic, who
said that they'd gotten
a letter from this woman.
It sounded interesting.
They were thinking
of funding her trip.
But was she a nut case?
Was she going to die out there?
Because they didn't want
"National Geographic-funded
explorer dies on week two."
And I said, well,
she's very intent.
She's very serious.
I've seen her maps.
I've seen the camels.
And he said, well, since you
guys are such good friends,
would you like to be the
photographer that we send out
to find her along the way?
So anyway, if we can
jump to the trailer.
This is a movie, which opened
last week all over the United
States.
Mia Wasikowska, this wonderful
actress, just-- it's so eerie.
I'll show you some
of the pictures,
but she looks exactly like
Robyn did during this trip.
And it's produced
by the same people
who did "The King's Speech."
And they're already talking
Oscar nominations for Mia.
So can we roll that?
OK, here we go.
Maybe bring the lights down
on us a little bit here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --walk across the Australian
desert from Alice Springs
to the Indian Ocean, a
distance of 2,000 miles.
When people ask me why I'm
doing it, my usual answer is,
why not?
-Your plan is ridiculous.
-Why don't you just
show them the trip?
Talina will come to you.
-I just want to be by myself.
-You must be mad, girly.
You know, that's about 2,000
miles, six months of hard walk.
-You want to die out
there or something?
[INSPIRATIONAL MUSIC]
-Leave me alone.
Go away!
I'm so alone.
-We all are.
[END PLAYBACK]
RICK SMOLAN: The
cinematographer,
a woman named Mandy Walker,
she did most incredible job
of capturing what it
felt like out there--
what the lake was
like, the dust.
Mia gives this amazing, very
understated performance,
where she says very little
and she communicate so much
in the film.
It was so eerie sitting
in the movie theater,
as you can probably
imagine, watching
literally my photographs
come to life, because they
took a lot of the pictures
and actually built the sets.
Actually, maybe if you could
jump to some of the pictures
while we're talking,
It would be fun.
I'll show you some
of the pictures.
And you see the real Robyn.
You see Mia back and forth,
and it's just really eerie.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: I got
to ask, what does it
feel like to see yourself
portrayed on film?
And did you pick Adam Driver?
RICK SMOLAN: No, no,
they chose that one.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: They
chose that one?
RICK SMOLAN: He's great.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Did you
feel like he portrayed you
in an accurate manner?
I can't imagine watching
someone play me on a big screen.
So how does that feel?
RICK SMOLAN: It was
very odd and eerie.
My brother is a
director in Hollywood
and said, look, you need
to realize that they're
going to-- those of you
who are into movies--
the arc of the character,
you have to start here.
And in real life, most
people don't change.
But in movies, everybody
starts here and ends up here.
So he said, basically,
they're going
to make you the irritating pest
at the beginning of the movie.
And then as you go on hopefully
by the end of the movie,
you redeem yourself.
And that was pretty
much what they did.
I mean, I think
they exaggerated.
As I said, I'm not a
fashion photographer.
And, of course, they had him
posing me and say, turn left.
Turn right.
Move your shoulders like this.
Which that would be like a "New
York Times" reporter making up
a quote.
But I'm fine with it.
I mean, I think the
director, John Curran,
did a wonderful job.
And we're doing a new book,
which is this book here.
I got to go back.
I shot tens of
thousands of photographs
during Robyn's trip.
And even though
National Geographic
did this-- where is it?
It's buried here.
So this was the cover.
You can be Vanna White.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Now, this
was the original cover.
RICK SMOLAN: So even though
they did a 32-page cover story,
which for any photographer,
32 pages is just unbelievable.
But I shot literally tens
of thousands of pictures.
And it's almost like
which of your children
make it into the lifeboat?
You have to choose
just-- you know?
So that's Robyn on
the left with her dog,
Diggity, and that's
Mia on the right.
They even put here
in the same blouse.
They went and manufactured
the same clothes
that we wore back then.
If you go to the next
picture, I sort of put
a lot of comparisons.
That's us on the left.
And that's Mia and
Adam on the right.
I don't know why they
felt it was necessary,
why they wanted to have
the actors look like us
or wear our clothes,
but it was kind of cool.
I mean, who would know the
difference other than you
now that we've kind of met?
But, I mean, it doesn't change
the entertainment value of it.
If you go to the next picture,
he's a little taller than me.
Roby's still gorgeous
as she was back then.
Actually at the end of the
movie it's kind of cool,
because they show-- at the very
end of the movie, Mia swims
underwater and the
credits come up,
and they go to the
original pictures
in National Geographic.
I've seen the movie quite a few
times now at film festivals.
And you hear people in the
audience go, oh my god,
that's right.
This actually happened.
Because you going in it's
based on a real story,
but when you actually see the
real Robyn and the real camels,
it makes the story
even more touching.
Can I share something
with your audience?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, of course.
RICK SMOLAN: I'm a
technology junkie.
So many of our books
have done something
like-- we were the first ones
ever to put a CD-ROM in a book.
It seems like a long time ago.
We were the first
people to ever do
a mass-customized best seller,
where every copy of "America
24/7" you could upload
your own photographs,
and you were on the
cover of our book,
but it was a "New York
Times" bestseller.
So this new book combines a
number of different things.
So first of all, it's really,
I think, kind of cool.
Pictures from Robyn's
original journey.
And this is a big wide book.
We're actually doing a
Kickstarter campaign right now
for this.
And so the first part
of it is actually
taking you through
her original journey.
She wrote a book
called "Tracks,"
which is why the
movie's called "Tracks,"
and she sold a million
copies in 18 languages.
But I'll show you
the coolest part,
which is that we have an app,
if can find the page here.
There's a free app you can
download called Aurasma.
It's made by HP.
And so throughout
the book, we've
done something kind
of cool-- I think
it's cool-- which
is you simply point
your phone at photographs.
There's a little picture of a
little icon of a phone here.
And this works on
Android or iOS.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Would it be
easier if I helped you hold it?
RICK SMOLAN: Yeah.
OK, so you can do that.
And then all I do is point
my phone at that photograph.
Let's see if I'm getting
good Wi-Fi in here.
Let's see.
Is it working?
I'm probably not getting
good signal here.
There we go.
And now it's playing
that scene in the movie.
So this is the scene of Robyn
writing to National Geographic.
Well, it's Mia writing
to National Geographic.
And so throughout
the whole book--
[RINGTONE CHIMING]
--you get to see.
[LAUGHTER]
MEI-MEI ZHAO:
Perfect time to call.
RICK SMOLAN: It's probably
Harvey Weinstein saying,
you can't do that.
So it's really kind of fun
to see the original Robyn
in the book, and then you
to see that scene as it
came to life in the movie.
And then-- I can do this
part-- so halfway-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: Were you the
first one to do this?
RICK SMOLAN: I think so.
I've never seen this done.
Before.
HP uses it for advertising.
So like in a magazine,
you point at a sneaker,
and then you can
rotate the sneaker.
But I think using this
in an editorial context
is really cool.
We did this actually last
year in "The Human Face
of Big Data," which
Google was a sponsor of.
And you could actually point
to different people in here.
They would give you their
TED Talk, basically.
So the still image--
what's so cool about it
is if I point to a
picture-- so here.
You'll get a kick out of this.
Here's National Geographic
from 1978, right?
Let me find this picture.
There's a picture Robyn sitting
by the campfire learning
to speak aboriginal dialects.
So this is the original copy.
Nothing's been done to it.
And I'll show you.
It actually works on an issue of
National Geographic from 1978.
People said, wait.
How did you embed something
in the picture in 1978?
And I didn't.
Let's see if this works.
OK.
So this is the scene of Adam.
This is Robyn by
the fire at night.
This is Adam and Mia
by the fire at night.
So it's actually like a
fingerprint technology.
It actually recognizes the
picture as a unique pattern.
And anywhere it sees
that, whether it's
a poster, on the internet, even
a fuzzy black and white picture
in a magazine, it'll trigger
that video, which is so cool.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: That's amazing.
RICK SMOLAN: The
fact that you can
do this with an old National
Geographic is just so freaky.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: That's incredible.
RICK SMOLAN: The Kickstarter
campaign that we're doing
is-- people said,
well, can't I just
buy this eventually on
Amazon if you get funded?
And the answer is yes.
But one of the
rewards is you get
a copy of the original
National Geographic
together with the book.
We've also got
prints from the book.
Anyway, I'm not
trying to sell you,
but if you're looking for
a cool gift for somebody--
But the second half of the
book is actually the movie.
So let me go back to that.
So these are now images.
The filmmakers allowed me to go
into the movie footage itself
and actually take still
frames out of the movie.
And this woman, Mandy
Walker, the cinematographer
I mentioned, was so good.
So I went through the
movie at one frame
a second on my
MacBook Air and found
images that looked
like still photographs
that a photojournalist
would take,
and then we associated
the screenplay with it.
So you get to meet
the real Robin.
Then you go back and you see
this is the campfire scene.
This is six color
printing spot varnish.
I couldn't find
anybody to publish it.
I went to all these publishers.
I mean, I've done pretty well
as a publisher over the years.
But they all said, oh,
it's too expensive.
What if the movie
doesn't do well?
I said, I want
six-color printing,
thick matte paper, spot varnish.
So my friends say, do
it as a Kickstarter.
And there's so many people
that love Robyn's story.
It's so inspiring.
And there's sort
of a mystery to it
also, which is that the
question is probably
the first question each of
you has is, why on earth
would somebody do this?
And I always think of
it like the Mona Lisa.
If we knew why the
Mona Lisa was smiling,
we wouldn't be talking
about the Mona Lisa.
And she didn't do
this purposely.
But I think it's a very
complicated answer of what
drove her to let go of society.
Imagine no GPS.
No phones.
No satellites.
I made her take a Flying
Doctor radio, which
is the one time she needed it.
It didn't work.
She was attacked by wild camels.
She said, sometimes on the
map, she'd come up to a place
where it would
show one road going
to the right, like a path, a
dirt road, and one to the left.
And she'd get there and
there'd be five roads.
Because since the
maps were done,
farmers would be
out there, ranchers.
People were just
basically driven so far
in this one direction, it
would become another road.
And she said on the map it
says, take the road on the left
and there'll be a well
two weeks along that road.
And she'd be walking
for two weeks going,
what if I took the wrong?
So she did right out of water.
I mean, it's an amazing
story how she survived.
And it isn't just luck.
I mean, so many of
the ways that she
solved your problems
were just so clever.
There's a scene in the movie
where she is with her dog
and she gets
separated the camel.
She's lost and she
goes back to find it.
And she finds the
thing that she's loss.
And then she turns around
and can't figure out
where she left the camels.
And she didn't take any
water, and she's with her dog,
and she's totally
freaking out and trying
to figure out what to do.
And I'm not going to
ruin it, but if you
want to see a movie
that you can't
stop thinking about afterwards,
it's playing at the Angelica
down here and at the Lincoln
Plaza Cinemas uptown.
But there's so many
things like that movie
where you see the fierce
intelligence of this woman.
And she's one of the
few people I've ever
met in my life who-- most of
us spend our lives avoiding
the things that frighten us.
And sometimes this negative
center of gravity-- it's
always pushing it away.
And I think she's the
only person I've ever
met that actually goes
towards the things
not in a masochistic
way but to see it as,
is that really worthy of
my spending my whole life
not doing something?
So I've never met anybody that
actually challenges themselves
all the time.
I was very inspired
spending time with her.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: That's amazing.
And she sounds incredible
and so does this film.
But how did you
feel about the trip,
especially now looking
retrospectively?
Was it as more difficult
and challenging
than you had expected?
RICK SMOLAN: I wasn't
even a Boy Scout.
So my friends said, you're
the ones getting back out
there, not her.
At least she's been
preparing for this.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: So, I'm going
to say, you did the trip too,
yeah.
You did the trip too.
RICK SMOLAN: I mean, I
had a four-wheel drive,
air-conditioned car, listening
to Jackson Browne in my care.
I'm really digging myself here.
I was 28 at the time, but
emotionally, I was about 19.
So every girlfriend
I'd had lasted a week,
and I'd get an assignment and it
never worked through anything.
And Robyn was one of these
people that would challenge.
There were just ways
she challenged herself.
She was always challenging me.
I remember earlier on the trip
on day one of the first times
I went out with her, we
were sitting around talking.
And she said, when
are you get here?
And I said, what?
And she'd been out there
about too much at that point.
And she said, when are
you going to get here?
And I thought, oh,
she'd gone nuts.
I mean, being out
there alone that much,
you get a little crazy.
And I said, Robyn, I'm sitting
right here in front of you.
I just couldn't imagine
what she was talking about.
And she said, no, you're not.
She said, since you
got here a day ago,
you've been talking about
your Time cover story
for Taiwan, where you're going
to leave the car in two weeks.
It's like you come out
here and you're everywhere
except with me.
It's like if you're going to
come out here, damn it, then
be here.
But don't spend the
whole time with me
planning what you're
going to do next
or thinking about what
you should done yesterday.
And it was one of those
things where somebody
goes like that to you, and
you kind of go, you know what?
You're absolutely right.
I mean, so many of us
spend our time in the past
or in the future and
never where we are.
I kept saying to her
throughout the trip,
you've got to keep a journal?
I mean, someday
you're going to want
to write a book about this.
And she said, why do you have to
turn everything into a product?
Like, why can't you
experience things and not
be always marketing and
packaging it and doing this?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: I
was going to say.
RICK SMOLAN: I guess I didn't
listen to that advice too well.
But it was like going to school.
And, of course, I
was smitten with her.
And--
MEI-MEI ZHAO: And this
blossoming romance.
RICK SMOLAN: It was
somewhat mutual.
I think it was probably
more on my side.
But it was the most
interesting year of my life.
And we're really
good friends still,
and we talk all the time.
The most fun thing
with the movie
was that I got to
go to Australia when
the movie came out.
And the filmmakers put us on
a two-week publicity tour.
We didn't keep
watching the movie.
We'd show up at the
end of the screenings
and do a Q&A with the audience.
And it was just so much
fun being with her again
and just comparing
memories, because we
are very different memories
of some of the trip as well.
It was just normal.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: So
part two of this
is bringing her in and
asking her side of the story.
RICK SMOLAN: Yeah,
when she's in New York,
she should come
and visit you guys.
Just one of the most
interesting people.
And everything's just
constantly original thinking.
It comes with things from
a different perspective
than most people.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Now, what is
she doing in New York City?
RICK SMOLAN: Right now,
she's back in Australia.
Actually, she's in Bali today
at a writer's conference.
Remember when we all
read "Catcher in the Rye"
growing up in school?
Her book, "Tracks," is
like that in Australia.
Every school kid reads "Tracks."
They actually have a
29-page study guide,
which we're actually
offering with this, too,
as the Kickstarter
thing, because it's
sort of very thought-provoking.
The kids talk
about, what is Robyn
say about aboriginal rights?
And why did she want to spend
time with the Aborigines?
And what was her
relationship with the camels?
I'll give you one
back story if you're
going to see the movie
that will actually
make you enjoy the
movie more, which
is that she had this wonderful
dog with her named Diggity.
And Diggity saved her life
many times during the trip.
It was like her daughter, her
companion, her sleeping bag,
confidant.
You talk to Diggity
all day long.
And this is not in the movie.
It's not even in her book.
But two years before
the camel trip,
Robyn was working as a janitor
at a hospital in Brisbane.
And so she'd come in at night
and clean all the garbage out.
And she heard these terrible
cries coming from the basement
and found out that they
were taking animals
from kill shelters
and using them
to experiment on dogs and cats.
And she just said she
couldn't stand it.
And she waited till
everybody was gone one night
and came back with the keys
and opened up all the cages,
opened all the doors, and
let all the animals out.
And there was one puppy
that had been brought
in that morning that
didn't run away.
And that was Diggity.
That became her dog.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: I'm
getting a tear in my ear.
RICK SMOLAN: When
you see the movie,
that story will
resonate with you.
Reviewers been saying that
amongst many other things
about this movie, the
relationship between Robyn
and her dog is something
you'll never forget.
It's just extraordinary.
Anyway, I'm getting
tears in my eyes too.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: All
right, so that's great.
I think I'm definitely
going to go see the movie.
I can't wait.
And now I think everyone in the
audience feels the same way.
So I do want to leave some
time to talk about "The Human
Face of Big Data," which
is a very exciting project.
Do you mind telling
us a little bit more
about "The Human
Face of Big Data"?
I think this would be the
audience who would enjoy it.
RICK SMOLAN: I'm a TED junkie.
I love going to TED and other
conferences-- ideacity and EEG.
And Marissa Mayer,
an old friend--
I met her at TED
probably 10 years ago.
And when she was
still at Google,
we were talking at TED one day.
And she said, so what's
your next project?
And I started doing these
geographic projects.
You know, "One Day in the
Life of America," coming out
of that first "Life"
assignment or Australia
or other countries.
And then I thought, what if
you could take the same idea?
So the concept of the
"Day in the Life" books
was I invited my
heroes, my peers,
and some young
photographers, and we
would spend months
getting ready.
But we'd fly them to a country
and we'd say, on your mark,
get set, go.
We'd distribute them
around the country
geographically and thematically
and say, OK, you got 24 hours.
Again, it got turned down by
every publisher in the world.
They said, what a stupid idea.
It's like, who would care about
a bunch of photographers taking
pictures on a day in
some godforsaken country?
And it became the
bestselling photography books
ever published.
I think we sold
five million copies.
20,000 was a best seller.
So I thought, what if we took
that same idea, and instead
of a geographic sort of random
"what happens in a day," what
if we did a deep dive on how the
human race is learning to heal
itself, or the global water
crisis, or-- Marissa's idea
was, why don't you
look at big data?
Because I was trying
figure out what to do?
And I said, what's that?
And she said, well,
some people say
it's so much
information it doesn't
fit in your personal computer.
And I said, that doesn't
sound very interesting.
And she said, well,
other people think
it's overlapping data
sets to find patterns.
And I said, I'm a photographer
and I don't get it.
And she said, OK,
a lot of us think
we're watching
the planet develop
a rudimentary nervous
system and that all
of us with our
smartphones are starting
to become sensors and nodes
on this growing brain.
And I said, whoa,
say that again.
And it was such a cool idea.
So she and her
husband, Zack, came
and spent a day
with us in New York
brainstorming how
to do this project.
She was so generous.
And the first thing
she pointing me to-- I
decide Eric Schmidt walking out
as we walked in this morning.
The first thing
Marissa pointed me to
was this wonderful
quote of Eric's saying
that of all the data from the
dawn of humanity to 2003--
I don't know how he figure
this out-- was five exabytes.
And now every two
days, the human race
is generating five exabytes.
Now, even if you don't know
what an exabyte is, and you all
do but I didn't
at the time-- I'm
still not quite sure I
do-- the fact that we're
seeing a straight vertical
line is unbelievable.
She also told me
that the first day
of a baby's life,
the human race is now
generating 70 times the amount
of information contained
in the Library of Congress
and that people walking
through Times Square are exposed
to as much information in one
day as our ancestors
from the 15th century
were exposed to in
their entire life.
So in every one of these, we're
seeing a straight vertical line
that's unlike anything
we've ever seen before.
So we figured, well, how
do you photograph that?
I mean, it's very
interesting, and these are all
great statistics.
So we did this book called
"The Human Face of Big Data."
And it's actually
remarkably human.
I'm just going to
open it anywhere.
And let's see if I can
find a story to give you.
And here's an example.
This is our Google
graphic that opened nicely
in the right place of all the
different arms and tentacles
of Google and all
the different ways
that your technologies
affect the world.
But there was a
really cool story.
Remember the earthquake
about five years ago?
This terrible earthquake.
And we're all talking about
the terrible destruction.
And I was listening to Kai
Ryssdal on National Public
Radio on "Marketplace," and
he was the only reporter
that talked about
that earthquake.
And he told us a
story-- I think it
was Steve Henn
was the reporter--
and said that 15 seconds
before the earthquake hit,
before the earthquake
hit, that every bullet
train, every factory in Japan
came to a halt, actually
stopped.
And they had put an early
warning system all over Japan.
I'm trying to find the
picture here somewhere.
I want to find it.
But they found that they
could actually put sensors
all over Japan that would
sense this P-wave that
became before the wave that was
actually the destructive wave.
And I thought, that's so cool.
They use these data centers.
But then I found out there's a
group of guys in Palo Alto that
realized that all of our
laptops have accelerometers
in them down.
And they wrote a program
called Quake-Catcher.
So before people
go to bed at night,
they fire up Quake-Catcher,
and they just leave it running.
And it actually is this
low-cost, ubiquitous,
completely free early
earthquake warning
system, which is amazing.
So the whole book is full
of stories like that.
There's a group--
MEI-MEI ZHAO: "A Day in a Life."
RICK SMOLAN: Yeah.
It's sort of how we're starting
to be able to understand cause
and effect in real time
in a way that we've never
been able to as
a species before.
An we put Eric's quote as
the opening page of the book.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: There's a quote
in here by Albert Einstein.
"Not everything that
can be counted counts
and not everything that
counts can be counted."
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[LAUGHING]
RICK SMOLAN: It's very
thought-provoking.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: It takes
a moment to process.
This is really amazing.
RICK SMOLAN: We had some
wonderful essays in it.
But it sounds like, well,
what would you photograph?
Like the Google data
servers with lights
blinking on them or something?
But it actually is
very, very human.
All the stories
in here-- we want
to put stories
where you couldn't
wait to tell your
friends, you've
got to look at the story.
It's so compelling.
Here, I'll give you one example.
I know we're probably
running late.
But there's a guy named Shwetak
Patel, who's 28 years old,
and this is his third startup.
And he said, imagine if you
got your America Express credit
card tomorrow, and there
was no itemization.
Would you pay your credit
card if it break down
what you spent your money on?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Some months
it might be better that way.
RICK SMOLAN: But
most people wouldn't.
And yet, we get an
electrical bill every month,
and we have no idea what
we're spending our money on.
So he invented a little gadget,
which he just sold the Belkin.
You plug it in
anywhere in your house,
and it'll give you literally
a read-out by device
in your house.
Every device doesn't have to
be plugged into this gadget.
You just plug it in
once in the house,
and it recognizes the digital
signature of every appliance.
And so now he can show
you what you spent.
And I said, well,
that's pretty cool,
but you still have
to pay the bill.
And he said, yeah.
I said, but did
you get an insight
from this data that makes
you change your behavior?
And he thought about it
for a minute, and he said,
you know what?
We actually found that
the average American
spends 11% of their monthly
electric bill on their DVR
that these devices weren't
designed to spin down.
So if you only record "The
Blacklist" on Monday night,
and the rest of the week
it's sitting there not
doing anything, it's
still spinning away.
So maybe we could lower
America's energy consumption
by just redesigning
the damn DVR.
So there's these
wonderful little insights
like that that came
out of the book.
Can I give you one last one?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, of course.
RICK SMOLAN: There's a company
in Boston called Ginger.io that
can predict you're going to get
depressed two days before you
get depressed, before you
show any outward signs
of depression.
So I said, well, first of all,
that sounded kind of wacky.
And I also said, why
would you want to do that?
And he said, well,
actually, we're
using it for medical purposes.
He said that people
with diabetes
apparently have very high
correlation with depression.
And when people
get depressed, they
stop taking their medicine.
And if you have diabetes,
you don't take your medicine,
there's very dire consequences.
So he said, we have this app.
It's called Ginger.io.
And basically, you install it
on your Android phone, your iOS
phone.
And it basically
creates a baseline
of what's normal for you.
And then two days before
you're showing any outward sign
of depression-- there's
20 different data points,
but it says your tweets and
emails and text are going down.
The amount of time you
spend at home goes up.
I mean, it has all
these different ways
of looking at a pattern.
I said, well, wouldn't that
just mean you're getting sick?
He said, no, we
have other things.
And he said, people actually
put this on their own phone.
And it says, if
it looks like I'm
going into one of those
terrible deep depressions,
call my neighbor or my doctor
or my brother or my sister,
whatever, just to make sure that
somebody checks in with them.
So again it's sort
of like-- they
call it the nurse
in your pocket.
And a lot of the new
medical applications
that you guys are
looking at Google
are using these sort of devices
that we're all carrying.
Some people get creeped
out by, and other people
think this is so cool.
It's a way of looking at
your life from 30,000 feet
and seeing the
pattern of your life.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, definitely.
I see that you're
wearing a Jawbone there.
I have one as well--
RICK SMOLAN: Yeah, I love this.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: --that
I'm not sporting.
But yeah, personalized data,
making informed decisions
with data is really [INAUDIBLE].
RICK SMOLAN: I was
surprised that the new Apple
Watch didn't mention sleep.
To me, sleep is the
most interesting part
of this little device.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yeah, me too.
Well, wonderful.
So I think with the last
10, 15 minutes or so, we're
going to open it up
for audience Q&A. We've
covered a lot of
ground today, and I'm
sure there's some questions
out in the audience.
RICK SMOLAN: They're
putting a spotlight on you.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: There's
a spotlight over there.
Well there's two mics,
one on each side.
Just for recording purposes,
if you have a question,
maybe you can step up to the
mic and ask Rick a question
on any of these topics.
RICK SMOLAN: I numbed
everybody into silence?
AUDIENCE: This is a
really quick question,
but did you go back to college
after you got the "Time" job?
RICK SMOLAN: I did.
In fact, I actually
stayed for two years
after I graduated, because
it was just too much fun
living at Dickinson
College in Pennsylvania.
So I stayed as the
yearbook photographer
after I was no longer
even a student.
It was really hard
to leave college.
I mean, I always think
of you actually you
at Google the same way.
I always remember the
stories of Larry and Sergey.
So I'm going from
college to Google.
And when I visited
Google the first time,
it felt like a big
college campus.
The thing that I love about
organizations like Google
is this idea of collisions,
this idea that you build
a facility where people run
into each other by accident.
And you overhear somebody
at the water cooler.
Or you're in a room
where suddenly a problem
you're trying to solve, you
run into just the right person
at the right time, because
the facility is designed
to allow those random meetings.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Fantastic.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So a problem that I'm
guessing you run into a lot--
and you told us a story
about running into this--
is a lot of times
people don't like
to get their picture taken.
So I'm wondering
how you approach
this when you're taking pictures
of strangers, how you handle
that and get them OK with
you taking their picture?
RICK SMOLAN: That's a
really good question.
And, oddly enough, I
find that most people--
[RINGTONE CHIMING]
I'm sorry.
I turned the sound on so you
could hear the videos working.
I actually find
most people don't
mind being photographed
as long as you
are comfortable
photographing them.
If you're taking a picture
sneakily of somebody
or-- I find the
people that get upset
are usually the ones that feel
like you're making fun of them.
So the one thing that my
wiser, older friends told me
when I was getting
started as a photographer
is if people get upset,
always walk over to them
and apologize and tell them why
you were taking the picture.
You look just like
my grandmother,
or I love the light on
you, or I'm a photographer,
and I'm sorry.
I didn't need to get you upset.
And 99% of the
time, people are--
as long as you don't
slunk away like you just
did something bad, they're fine.
It's so funny how
your being confident
makes them feel comfortable.
A lot of times,
especially when you're
working in countries where
you don't speak the language,
just making eye contact and
smiling and saying-- you
get really good
at sign language.
And sometimes
people do get upset.
I find-- this is my
bad generalization.
I'm sure somebody who's
watching this afterwards
will write me a nasty letter.
But I find that a
lot of times when
people don't like
being photographed,
it's because they have a
negative opinion of themselves.
They've been made fun of,
or they're feeling somehow
your taking a picture of them
is ridiculing in some way.
And mostly when I
photograph people,
it's because I find
them or where they are
or what's happening interesting.
I don't know if that answers
your question or not.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, definitely.
Thank you.
RICK SMOLAN: Cool.
Thanks.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Do you
find these days with--
RICK SMOLAN: Everyone's
now taking pictures of me.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Everyone's
now taking pictures.
But I think the
privacy issue of now
if you take a picture of
someone, you can upload it,
and it becomes public entity.
You find it a little bit more
difficult to take pictures now?
Or is it just because
photos are so common
now that people are desensitized
to others taking photos?
RICK SMOLAN: I'm going to answer
your question a little bit
differently, because
I'm thinking about this.
Some of you may
remember the time
where it was a novel
idea to actually put
a modem in a computer.
Like, gee, you mean
computers might
want to actually
talk to each other?
And you'd actually have a
separate 300-baud modem,
and it would make this
[SCREECHING] noise.
And the first time someone
said to me "always on"-- like,
you would have a Wi-Fi
network in your house,
and you wouldn't dial in.
You wouldn't turn the
internet on or off.
It would always be on.
It's like, why would you
want it to always be on?
What would you
possibly do with it?
Well, this actually
correlates to Google Glass.
And some of the things
I've been thinking about
is, what if we start
wearing devices
that record everything in 360?
There's a company here in New
York called [? Bemuse ?] that
has a football helmet with
a little bubble on top.
And literally as the guys
are running down the field,
it's not spinning.
It's actually reporting in 360.
And then you at home
can sit there and decide
if you want to look to the
right or the left to the player,
either in real
time or afterwards.
So I'm wondering
what the world's
like, just the way that
it seemed odd to me
that you'd want
always-on internet.
What if, as we all
walk around, there's
this 360 degrees
sphere of recording
where a year from now,
somebody could literally
fly from one side of
the room to the other
just by going through this
sphere around that was recorded
around, where it's free?
It's ubiquitous.
It's everywhere.
And what does that
do to privacy?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: I just reread
"Nineteen Eighty-Four"
recently, and that right
now really scares me
with the whole idea of
Big Brother and privacy.
But that's a whole
other discussion.
RICK SMOLAN: Do you remember
in "Nineteen Eighty-Four,"
the TVs would watch you?
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Yes.
Exactly that.
RICK SMOLAN: So
Apple has a patent
that they recorded
nine years ago where
every pixel on the
screen is not only
emitting light but recording it.
When you guys make a conference
call and you're doing Skype
or whatever it is,
the camera's here
and the person you're
talking to is here.
So you're looking up here,
and you're not really
making eye contact.
Well, I'm just thinking
of this Apple patent.
I don't know what
they're doing with it.
I have a friend who follows
patents, and he always,
look at this.
The is so cool.
Apple may do this
and or Google might.
But this idea that
you're actually
looking into the
eye of other person,
making eye contact
through the screen
may have an
incredible difference
in terms of this whole idea
of virtual conferencing.
Sorry.
You could tell my brain is
goes at 40 directions at once.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Is everywhere.
All right, I think I
have one more question.
I have time for
one more question.
We have one more question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So I really admire your
work as a photographer.
And I'm sure you get this
question a lot of times.
But I was wondering
if you have any advice
to give someone who's looking
to stand out or succeed
as a photographer today,
especially when I think
photography has been
more democratized
with the digital
cameras and everything?
RICK SMOLAN: Well,
first of all, I
think people appreciate
photography more now,
because everyone's
doing it and using it
and we all incorporate it into
our PowerPoint presentations
in Keynote.
If you see the movie,
I do the opposite
of what Adam does in the movie.
Adam is in her face saying,
do this, do that, turn here,
and do that.
I actually kind of
disappear into the woodwork.
When I photograph
people, they get board.
I mean, I want them to.
I want them to forget
I'm even there.
It's really hard.
You know how we all
have a photo face?
When somebody has
a camera, we have
the same look that we all have.
But if somebody actually spent
a week photographing you,
they would get the real you,
because eventually you'd
just go back to what
you're going to do,
because you just can't
keep the photo face on.
And so I always felt
like the pictures
I took of Robyn and Natasha
and my best pictures were
when people just literally
forgot I was there.
I mean, I don't
know if I'm boring.
But I'm pretty quiet.
You wouldn't believe
that for this talk.
And Olivia, who sort of runs
my life now as my assistant,
doesn't believe I'm quiet.
But anyway, when
I'm shooting, I try
to blend into the wallpaper.
And I figured that I
think that's a secret
that most people-- they take
the picture and they leave.
It's sort of fly-by photography.
And I had the luxury
as a photographer
of spending a lot
of time with people.
Even when I got a
one-day assignment,
if the person I
was photographing
would let me stay there, I
would spend three or four days.
The magazine wouldn't
pay me for it,
but I just felt like I
would do a better job.
So I would always
over-deliver, and I
think that's why I
kept getting hired.
So I don't know if
that helps or not.
AUDIENCE: No, that's good.
Thank you.
RICK SMOLAN: OK, sure.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Great, and one
last question that I want
to ask you is,
"Humans of New York"--
RICK SMOLAN: Yeah.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: -- the series--
RICK SMOLAN: It's very cool.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: --has
really taken off.
What are your thoughts on that?
And you think that's a
modern day of-- you know,
"A Day in the Life"
and just really trying
to capture moments of various
people, various cultures
across in a very real way.
So now they have
a picture and they
have a little
description, a quote.
RICK SMOLAN: Of the
day or something.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Of the people.
So it'll ask a
question like, what
was the saddest
time of your life?
What was your last best
memory or something?
I don't know what your--
RICK SMOLAN: The thing I like
about "Humans of New York"
is the acknowledgment that
every single one of us
has a story to tell.
And you don't have to be famous.
You don't have to be rich.
I mean, if you ask
the right questions
and you talk to people,
every single person
that you meet has got an
interesting story to tell.
And I think, to me,
that's what really
emerged from that whole project.
I think I really admire
the guy that did it.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Good.
Well, I think that's all
we have time for today.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
RICK SMOLAN: Thank you so much.
MEI-MEI ZHAO: I think this
has been a fantastic hour.
And thank you everyone here
for coming to our talk.
RICK SMOLAN: Please
tell your friends about
out Kickstarter campaign,
"Inside Tracks."
MEI-MEI ZHAO: Thank you.
RICK SMOLAN: Thank you.